They're rapists.
And some, I assume, are good people.
The idea of completely discounting Mexicans
and talking about your second most important
trading partner in that way.
We have some bad hombres here and we're going
to get 'em out.
That's not the art of the deal, that is just
very bad business.
Hi, I'm Nick Gillespie for Reason,
and today we're talking with Roberto Salinas.
He's the president of the Mexico Business
Forum,
and he is a persistent and vocal critic of
Donald Trump.
Roberto, thanks for talking to Reason.
It's a great pleasure to be here, Nick.
Let's talk about NAFTA first and your role
in it.
Is NAFTA a good thing or a bad thing for Mexico,
Canada and the US?
It's getting a lot of heat lately.
In the early 1990s, we thought,
"Well, wow! Mexico's already a story of trade liberalization.
We're exporting 35 billion dollars a year
worth of products and so on.”
Today that number is 365 billions,
so from a trade perspective, and this is a
trade agreement,
from a trade perspective,
I don't think there's any question that NAFTA
has been a success in the sale side.
And then you go to the purchase side, in other
words, imports,
and you find that you're also importing a
vast amount.
Guess where those imports come from?
In about 80 percent, the United States.
Yeah, exactly.
So those in Indiana depend ...
I mean, speaking of Mike Pence,
does Indiana depend on jobs because of its
trade with Mexico?
Does Ohio?
Texas?
You want to shut down NAFTA?
That turns Texas into a democratic state overnight.
Where do you think the animus against NAFTA,
particularly in the United States, and I mean,
this is something that Donald Trump ran on.
It's also something that Bernie Sanders brought
up a lot,
the idea that somehow free trade agreements
suck jobs out of America
and they put them in third-world countries,
which due to a lot of economic ignorance,
often times they're talking about Mexico as
a third-world country, as well.
Where does the resentment of something like
that come from?
I think that was one of the great lessons
of the Trump campaign, the Bernie Sanders
campaign.
It's not something that discriminates between
Republicans and Democrats
or between the right or the left or whatever.
What you found out is that there is anger
because there's displacement.
There is job displacement, and that's a very
serious concern.
But are we going to address it by closing
our economies?
By building walls?
I mean, wasn't another famous Republican the
one who said, "Tear down this wall."
The same one that said, "We will always keep
our doors open in the shiny city on the hill
no matter how many walls it may have."
I think those principles have to be kept in
mind, but also,
to be very serious about trying to alleviate
the disruption and the displacement
that may come in this era of globalization
for those that have lost their jobs.
you mentioned Indiana and Ohio.
You can throw Michigan and Wisconsin
states that were very important for Donald
Trump to win.
It's clear that the anti-NAFTA message resonated
there.
How do you help workers who may have been
displaced
by the idea that certain types of industrial
jobs go elsewhere.
Oh my goodness!
That is a hard question.
I think you would have to come in three tranches,
but this is something purely speculative.
The first is that you need some type of, hopefully,
market-oriented job loss insurance,
that may be funded through the tremendous
economic exchange
that is done on a trilateral basis,
only on a temporary point of view, in other
words,
as just a measure to alleviate the immediate
pain.
But then you need something that's more structured,
and that would have to be based on retraining,
on education and on trilateral efforts,
hopefully, more private-oriented than public-oriented,
to try and find new workspaces for such people.
And I think this is something that independently
of NAFTA is an issue in the United States
in the next 10 years with the tremendous advances
of technologies,
because those job displacements owe a lot
more
to technological disruption and progress than
they due to trade.
Right, yeah, I mean-
And third world, by the way, the idea that
low wages are sucking ...
It's more affordable and more productive worker
units.
You go down to Hermosillo, Sonora, where they
have the Ford plant there,
which has suspended production on one of its
Ford models,
but otherwise Haiti would be the richest country
in Latin America.
Otherwise, many of these sub-Saharan countries
would be by far the most prosperous ones.
How does the Mexican business community view
somebody like Donald Trump?
I mean, are they worried?
Not just because of his rhetoric, but that
he'll do policies
that actually do real damage to the ability
for the Mexican economy,
or the North American economy to grow?
Well, at first, there was a significant worry.
We have to understand that NAFTA for Mexico
was much more than a trade and an investment
agreement.
It was importing the credibility of US institutions.
If you do investment on a North American level,
chances of a future government in Mexico trying
to derail that,
as it happened to us before, are going to
be a lot harder.
So that straitjacket effect perhaps is not
golden, but it certainly a silver straitjacket.
Somebody may want to re-nationalize, re-expropriate
the banks
or they may want to do all kinds of horrible
things in the populist tradition
that has characterized many Latin American
countries.
NAFTA was a great step forward in trying to,
not preclude that completely,
but significantly lessen the probability of
a future change,
and that's what led to a great deal of investment
coming into Mexico.
It was that credibility that was imported.
In that sense, for Mexico the idea of abandoning
NAFTA ...
We'll still trade with the United States at
an enormous level.
Mexico today is the number one supplier of
auto parts in the United States,
the number two supplier of automobiles in
the United States.
NFL helmets are produced in Mexico, assembled
in Mexico.
Pretty sure avocados.
You guys have cornered the American market.
The greatest lie, fake news ... Can't even
call them that.
It's just an outright lie.
The facts speak very differently about the
effect of NAFTA
on Mexican agriculture, on the country.
It's exploded.
It's exploded, and I myself have friends
and many people that ...
I don't know this from reading a statistic,
I know this from actually visiting the different
farms, whether it's tomato ...
You know, many of the tomatoes we eat in the
best restaurants
in Las Vegas or in New York or in Los Angeles,
they come from Sinaloa.
So you're saying Mexican tomatoes are taking
American tomatoes jobs?
No, I'm not saying-
You're selling Trump's idea.
I'm saying that Donald Trump,
when he goes and eats at Daniel Boulud, he
doesn't know ...
In is a very expensive dinner, that he's actually
the one that's unemploying American ...
Now, why isn't there room for both?
Why don't you let consumers choose at the
end of the day?
This leads, I think, to a great deal of fallacies
concerning the trade deficit.
I mean, the intellectual backwardness of many
of Trump's trade advisors
contrasts dramatically with some of the very
good advice he's gotten in terms of deregulation
and in terms of taxes and in terms of draining
the swamp.
When Donald Trump announced for the presidency,
literally within five minutes he went on a
rant.
They're bringing drugs, they're bringing crime.
They're rapists.
And some, I assume, are good people.
What kind of anger or resentment does that
stir in you
or in Mexicans broadly along with it,
increasingly xenophobic rhetoric,
both coming out of the Republican Party, but
many other parts of America?
I'll tell you what it has done.
It has empowered Andrés López Obrador,
who is our equivalent of Hugo Chávez.
A rabid, primitive, vitriolic populist.
He's on the top for the 2018 presidential
election, today.
He's leading on the polls, and that's because
he has ...
Donald Trump became his number one campaign
advisor with that vitriol.
So, instead of talking to each other,
because that's usually what classical liberals
do,
they learn how to talk to each other and listen
to each other,
the idea of completely discounting Mexicans
and talking about your second most important
trading partner in that vein,
is just that's not the art of the deal.
That is just very bad business.
There's other ways of going around it.
Look at the Republican Doug Ducey in Arizona,
talking with Claudia Pavlovich in Sonora.
They don't no longer want to distinguish the
states.
They want to talk about the megaregion
and how they can compliment each other's what?
Comparative advantage?
Has Donald Trump ever heard of that word?
Has Peter Navarro ever read Adan Smith?
David Ricardo?
We're speaking at Freedom Fest in Las Vegas,
the world's largest annual gathering of libertarians
and free market people.
Two years ago, Donald Trump actually spoke
here
and you had a heated exchange with him.
You asked him a tough question.
Recount for us what the question was,
what his response was, and either do you feel
like you got through at all.
Well no, actually, I felt rather humiliated.
The man does know how to manage the stage.
What I asked him was whether he would build
a wall in every single state
within the United States to keep Nebraska
bad hombres out of Missouri
and the bad element of Florida out of Washington
state,
and what that would do to the economy,
because by that logic, that's what you should
do
and for that matter municipalities and whatnot.
And so he said, "No," he would build the wall
just for Mexico
and he accused me of being sent by the Mexican
government.
Did the government of Mexico ask you to come
up here and make this?
Oh of course, of course,
Go ahead ask your question, ask your question,
come on you got a lot of people waiting.
Were you in fact sent by the Mexican government?
Of course not.
You were sent by the Russian government.
Or the Haitian government or maybe the Tahiti.
Do you feel like xenophobia is on the rise
in the NAFTA zone?
I mean, are people in an age where economic
growth
in many cases globally has been slowing down,
certainly in the United States in the 21st
century,
economic growth has been much lower that it
had been for the previous 50 or 60 years,
is that breeding kind of resentment or a sense
of,
"We're fighting over a shrinking pie,"
and that, "We've got to keep out people who
we think aren't like us or can't become us"?
That I think is a very important challenge.
There's definitely an ingredient of xenophobia.
I think we're still in time to curtail it.
Mexican business people and the government
have learned
that a lot of what Donald Trump says, a lot
of the vitriol and the venom are just that.
They're rhetoric, and in reality we'll talk
about renegotiating NAFTA,
but what does that entail?
That may actually provide an opportunity to
develop, for instance,
new technologies to allow trucks on both sides
of the border
to cross, maybe a special bridge, after you
do full disclosure
after you agree to be completely surveilled
by satellites and whatnot.
And maybe that can even pay a little piece
of a wall
that we'll still take 27 years to build or
some such,
by the way, probably by Mexican workers and
Cemex, Mexican cements,
so that may not be all bad for us.
But it's the message is what hurts, is,
"You're going to pay for it.
I'm going to force you to pay for it."
That's just not good diplomacy
and that feeds that xenophobia north of the
border, but it also feeds it elsewhere.
Donald Trump is not a highly regarded leader
of the free world
and the rest of the world because of his antics
and because of the reality TV that he lives
in
and because of this fantasy, Freudian complex
that he might have,
that he wants to be number one
and he wants to tweet at every moment of the
day that he's number one.
That's not how you're going to get things
done.
That's not the art of the deal in statesmanship
and leadership in the global arena.
We will leave it there, but the final question,
of course
that I ask anybody from Mexico who is a classical
liberal or libertarian.
Friedrich Hayek or Salma Hayek?
Who's your favorite Hayek?
Oh my goodness!
That's an impossible question,
but I would have to say Friedrich.
Well, I want to thank Roberto Salinas.
He is the president of the Mexico Business
Forum,
for talking to us while we're at Freedom Fest
in Las Vegas.
Roberto, thanks so much.
Thank you, Nick.
For Reason, I'm Nick Gillespie.